your speed dating continues with me yes
I want to start with congratulations on
the sequel I sincerely hope it's a you
chat let's keep them let's keep going
thank you right uh so I I don't want to
spoil anything about the movie but
um if you were able to actually leave
set wearing your costumes where is the
place you would really like to go and
why oh boy the Beltline oh well if we
have to be in Atlanta it could be
anywhere well you can go anywhere with
the costume yeah I'll I'll go to the
Children's Hospital
yeah I'm not I'm not opposed to that I
love that I'll go with them yeah Zach
said that as well and honestly like you
guys should totally do that but some of
the other castmates mentioned Hollywood
Boulevard which also would be a cement
like 100 bucks just to walk around and
like pretend but like see how long it
takes right you know we could buy lunch
that way yeah get some lunch money um I
would oh boy where else could you go
that would be fun
um go to Africa and go to Safari no it
doesn't seem the animals aren't gonna
care you're gonna be hot I don't know
the animals might care they might care
as they eat you exactly this bright
shiny object where else I'll drop my
I'll drop like my daughter off at school
that's awesome equal parts embarrassing
for both of us as it would actually love
it you know you know that would be pick
them up even better pick them up right
oh every aspect of that would be amazing
yeah yeah no 100 one of the things that
I think David does so well with these
movies is that he balances this like
humor and fun with like pretty dark
stuff yeah you know and like that horror
elements come through can you can you
sort of talk about that aspect when I
first saw the first one I was like
literally like I was like can we can we
do this is like a children's film right
I was like wait I was like but it was so
awesome because horror is my favorite
genre so
um I think the way that he does it is so
brilliant and so smart and I think it's
something that's just so unique and
specific to him and his sensibility and
I think it makes the film you know
automatically like you know when you see
an animated film it's like a lot of
adults are like no but then when you see
a certain type of humor that you know
only we get you know you suddenly know
this film is for everybody and so I
think that Shazam has that where this
film feels like it's literally for
everybody I think you know you can tell
he loves it you can tell he's from
you know from there and has a real uh
talent and affinity for it and so lean
into it you know uh um I loved it and
the first one you know a couple of
shocking horror elements I I think it
was over the top or I didn't think it
was too you know in some ways it's more
wholesome to me than like
PG-13 gun play you know I'd rather have
monster bite off someone's head no one's
going to emulate it
um you know
um so yeah I love it I love it the more
the more David horror the better as far
as I'm concerned uh well for both of you
what was your reaction when you actually
saw the scripture we're told how much
bigger the roles were gonna be because
you guys are like big parts of the
sequel that was one mystical monster I
was like what this is a bit it was like
a very darling moment I was so excited
yeah
um but uh yeah I mean just reading the
script and I'm like okay wow this is
about to be so much bigger
um and then seeing it on set and then
seeing it and you know watching it in
the screening and stuff it's just it's
it's much more epic and it's like now
you know it's not just saving you know
people it's like saving the world and so
yeah it's pretty badass yeah I I thought
there was I I really liked this script a
lot I am I thought all the Easter eggs
were very well done on and it it had a
lot of nice satisfying I would say
surprises as well as um
I thought emotionally too reading it I I
I thought it worked it hit pretty well
um but yeah yeah I know that Zach likes
to play music yes on set I've asked
everybody about this uh do you enjoy
that part some people like silence
before I take and like quiet but like
what was it like working with someone
who's blasting music and can you share a
little bit of what you know what was
like on set I loved it I loved it too I
mean this is that kind of film you know
you know as as Adam's been saying it's
like you know you put on the costumes
and you instantly feel silly and free
and like your inner child is coming out
and then you've got Zach playing this
music and Ron they're just dancing and
doing all kinds of different stuff in
our suits and
um it was pretty it was pretty amazing
and there's a lot of down time there's a
lot of costume stuff uh
um um adjustments so it's not like you
got a lot of time to kill in a suit and
it's it's hard to like take your book
with you and you know and so it's it's
great to have keep the vibe going and
the energy up he just we just did a
photo shoot upstairs to start this often
he brought his his speaker and was
playing and I was happy for it yeah yeah
which is why you just have to leave set
and go to Starbucks wearing the costume
I'm joking I'm joking on that note I
gotta go um good luck with the rest of
your day thank you thank you for your
time